ever since the onset of the dollar flu
outbreak and the activation of the
division agents we've seen a countless
number of once loyal shd agents turn
drug is this a sign of poor recruitment
and preparation from the strategic
homeland division or are they most
sensitive reasons behind a potential
collapse of the United States last line
of defense
[Music]
you
so are the shd really the good guys to
answer that let's very quickly summarize
what the shd is on May 4th 2007
President Bush signed the National
Security presidential directive 51 this
mandate claimed the executive power to
invoke and direct continuity of
government procedures in the event of
catastrophic emergency this was
primarily created as a direct response
to the findings of operation dark winter
which was a mock version of a covert and
widespread smallpox attack on the United
States carried out in 2001 once
directive 51 has been invoked the prison
connector vac TSH DS highly-trained core
of sleeper agents embedded across the
nation and immediately commenced
operations basically when directive 51
has been activated the executive branch
takes on the leading role by passing and
superseding the traditional roles and
processes of the federal government and
this is all coordinated by the president
the official shd mission statement reads
the strategic homeland division mission
is to protect the populace and secure
the continuation of the United States of
America and times of catastrophic
emergency no matter the cost
acting as an extension of the president
we will assist the federal and state
actors by providing a unified picture of
any national crisis and guide them to
the decisions that are in the best
interest of the people our mandate is to
take action wherever and whenever needed
to fight rising threats against the
security of the nation that's people to
seize back control and do whatever it
takes to save what remains the strategic
homeland division is a decentralized
autonomous entity and doubt with
executive powers and rules of engagement
and restricted by legal constraints
trained to operate in deadly chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
environments the division is mandated to
bring order stability and justice to
communities shattered by catastrophic
events the agency also pledges active
support to the classified continuity of
government plans should a widespread
national disaster [ __ ] its normal
governing functions basically they can
do anything they deem necessary to
assist them in the mission they are not
bound by laws or the usual rules of
combat and answer only to the president
so given that they only answer to the
president who police is such a force
well this is somewhat where Isaac comes
in access to the sh t network is one of
the most important tactical tools in the
division agents toolset every field
operative is linked via his or her
personal intelligence system analytic
computer or Isaac Isaac was developed by
the Pentagon's DARPA unit its primary
job is to provide key field operational
services to every agent including
communications real-time analytics
remote data collection and retrieval
with a telemetry and interaction with
assorted other technologies summing up
Isaac is an advanced learning AI system
if you really want to go tinfoil hat on
this the voice behind Isaac in both the
first and second game is an American
actor by the name of Brenton kina nuff
said really if you want to go down that
path we could just say that Isaac was
programmed and manipulated by Aaron
Tina's brother and leave her there
anyway AI degrees Isaac also has the
built-in function of flaking an agent as
rogue if they disavow the rules of the
division and all division agents have a
standing order at which to deal with
rogues should they come across them they
had to be hunted down and either killed
or apprehended according to the degree
of their crimes rogue status is given to
any agent who breaks protocol when the
status is given to an agent the
wristwatch will change from orange to
red and they'll have the connection to
the Isaac Network severed
[Music]
I'll repeat that line rogue status is
given to any agent who breaks protocol
but what is division protocol they have
a very loose set of guidelines to follow
and all the power and freedom in the
world to do what they deem as necessary
if we bring back the key words that are
read through earlier protect the
populace secure the continuation of the
United States of America the best
interest of the people this is taken
directly from the strategic homeland
division mission statement this is a
division agents objective and the reason
they were activated however there is
nothing that goes into the specifics of
how they're to achieve this and what is
the right or wrong way of doing it and
this is done on purpose these agents are
called upon to work autonomously and
potentially have no support that they
can call on they're expected to make
calculated decisions in situations that
few people could ever predict happening
and unfortunately some of these
decisions may cause loss of life in
order to save the lives of many others
but how would I react to that as an
agent expected to die a hero potentially
saving no one or withdraw to fight
another day as we know there are a
number of rogue agent stories out there
a vehicle Chica for example finding
himself trapped in the DZ with a group
of civilians under heavy fire from
hostile forces he quickly radioed for
assistance from the JTF but was denied
as they head orders from the government
to withdraw from the area immediately
because of the scourge eco is forced to
make the decision between either staying
behind with the civilians with a high
probability of dying or retreating and
in turn being flaked as rogue and there
are a number of stories out there like
this being rogue isn't always just about
being straight up evil villains who
murder other agents or people are
clapping the theater at the end of a
movie it could actually be the
consequence of a quick calculated
decision either misguided or otherwise
based on the circumstances and the
important role in agent plays and
protected in numerous lives thus
resulting in possible civilian
casualties in order to be around to
fight another day and that may be the
person in question still has the best of
intentions
I do wonder would katika still have gone
on a crazy jtf killing spree if he
hadn't been given the rogue status well
possibly he was definitely a little
crazy and to be fair that one's probably
more on the incompetent sh t recruiters
than anything else let's face it Isaac
is a computer and it only knows what
it's programmed to know zeros and ones
yes and no on and off yes it's a
learning AI but that's probably only
making it get tighter on what parameters
it would constitute giving a rogue
status now I'm not saying that all
rogues are good by any means there are a
number that have reacted in completely
unprecedented ways when faced with
adversity and as a result some of
ultimately gone off the rails done their
own thing and for no other reason that
would seem then to create chaos in fact
with the introduction of warlords of New
York we've seen a number of different
examples of rogues we have some that
have just given up on the government and
they're just out there trying to survive
in their own ways more or less keeping
to themselves and we have the ones
working with kina though from what we've
seen so far a lot of these have either
been forced or manipulated into
following it and then we have some that
have aligned with the other side the
black tusk so what do we know about the
black tusk we know they're a private
military contractor that has been
employed by an unknown organization they
were hired to pave the way for a new
dynasty and to do this they were tasked
with dismantling and eliminating any
functioning order of the US government
including the strategic homeland
division now immediately you see these
as the bad guys right with the shd we
fight for the president and the people
of the United States but what if they're
not the shd reports to one person the
president and now he works for them so
does that mean the shd now work for the
black tusk well you know president Ellis
has been labeled as a traitor but with
him gone and the rest of the higher
leadership either did or m.i.a
the shd has essentially now failed that
part of the mission
so with that lost what they're left
protect the populace the best interest
of the people with this in mind who
sounds like the best chance for the
United States which group is more likely
to bring peace to the people a legalized
group of vigilantes with now no current
leadership or the black tusk the
division has been losing people to this
group since the outbreak first occurred
so there must be something there my
personal opinion for what it's worth is
there I don't trust the black tusk why
would the organization behind them
continue to hide themselves if they were
really fighting for the country and what
exactly do they propose to do with their
new dynasty but given what the Sh deal
working with the bare bones that remain
of civilization no government and
plummeting numbers that maintain what
little control they currently have maybe
the black tasks are the best option of
putting it into all the current
suffering maybe we need to forget the
politics and be prepared to swallow the
bullet that may or may not come in order
to put an end to the fighting and
finally start rebuilding the country
again my personal opinion the strategic
homeland division is a failed experiment
the agency was brought to life for the
greatest of intentions but in practice
it just didn't really play out people no
matter how thoroughly tested are too
unpredictable to give too much power to
and I'm talking about both the president
and the agents obviously there could
have been much better screening on this
psych evaluations from the Commons we
can see that there was too much in the
way of personal opinion making the calls
where it should have been based on a set
of criteria pass or fail no gray areas
actually there could've been something
that Isaac would have handled quite well
the shd has only made it this far
because of a few loyal agents absolutely
true to the cause including one crazy
ex-girlfriend type that no one would
miss with but is it all in vain are they
trying too hard to support a government
that no longer exists and are they
forgetting about the needs of the people
during all of this but what do you think
are the shd fighting for a lost cause
are they just prolonging the inevitable
and averted lis causing more harm in the
process and do you think Isaac should be
downgraded to an elixir 2.0 something
this has just been another one of those
videos where I talk talk talk hopefully
you are able to follow my train of
thought
I tend to get a bit carried away
sometimes I'm going to explore this
topic further I'd like to put some notes
together around the black tusk and
speculate on what could actually be
going on there but that could take me a
while to throw together I have a number
of other personalities to come first and
possibly an update to the hunter
theories an extremely helpful member on
discord has been feeding me some
interesting ideas and information anyway
thank you very much for watching I hope
you've enjoyed this and I'll catch you
in the next one Cheers
[Music]
[Music]